Joe Biden cowers to the woke mob GOP rep
Matt gates fights global warming on the
left's terms and AOC misses her own
advice that the Internet is forever we
will analyze bad politics then some men
think they're women some men think
they're puppies and finally the mailbag
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
poor Joe Biden poor poor Joe Biden you
know I have been sort of defending him
all week I've been defending him against
the charges that he's a sexual predator
or now what people are telling me people
are tweeting to me they said Michael how
can you defend Joe Biden he's groping
children
he's group do you really believe just
stop yourself for a minute because this
sometimes ideology does this to us or
sometimes opportunism does this to us
stop yourself for one second do you
honestly believe that Joe Biden is a
child molester and that we didn't know
about it or some people knew about it
because they saw the videos and and they
saw the pictures of he had his hand on a
girl's head there was something when he
was taking a photo in the Senate and but
we just we didn't we didn't really know
we didn't really act on it until right
now the minute that he's declaring that
he's running for president but actually
he's been a child molester for 40 years
and we just die and some of us knew but
I guess we didn't care enough to make it
a big deal does do you really believe
that no of course not however Joe Biden
is sunk Joe Biden it is going to be very
very difficult for Joe Biden to dig
himself out of this hole why well seven
women total have come out against Joe
Biden the people who have orchestrated
this attack and make no mistake this is
a well orchestrated political attack it
looks like a lot of it is coming out of
the Sanders campaign but who knows once
these things get rolling more people
come out whoever orchestrated this
attack has done a really great job
because it's a slow drip it's a very you
had that one woman who is the big
Sanders activist who said Joe Biden
smelled my hair 10 years ago and
therefore he's a sick monster assailant
then you had a couple other women one
woman said Joe Biden rubbed my nose or
something he smiled at me five years ago
and therefore he's a misogynist he hates
women and now a
few more women Joe Biden hugged me too
long once Joe there was one woman who
said I asked Joe Biden to take a picture
with me and my husband and when we took
the picture he put his hand on my back
therefore he's a sexual predator because
he took it how do you take a photo
smile hands on the back hey how you
doing so now more women have come out
seven women in total one woman this is
my favorite one she told The Washington
Post that she had framed a photo the
photo of Joe Biden nuzzling with her
friend had printed it out for her she
actually had framed this photo because
it was really cool she's got this photo
of the vice president being affectionate
with her and only years later did she
take it down during the me2 movement
because she decided ex post facto that
it was a sexual assault when she took it
she really liked it framed the
photograph then years later it's a
sexual assault because of this mass
political hysteria and this cynical
attack even so even with seven women
coming out and saying Joe Biden shook my
hand once therefore he's a rapist or
whatever they're saying the reason he's
sunk is not because of all that this
would have blown over the reason he's
sunk is because he's giving in to the
woek mob the reason he's sunk is because
he is accepting their premises and now
it's probably over expect to be talking
about a whole lot of issues and I'll
always be directly but today I want to
talk about just as the support and
encouragement that I've made to women
and some men have made them
uncomfortable and I always tried to be
in my career I've always tried to make a
human connection that's my
responsibility I think I shake hands I
hug people I I grab men and loom by the
shoulders and say you can do this social
wars that began to change they've
shifted and the boundaries of protecting
personal space have been reset and I get
it I get it
I hear what they're saying I understand
it and I'll be much more mindful that's
responsibility my responsibility and
I'll meet it but I'll always believe
governing quite frankly life for that
matter it's about connecting about
connecting the people that won't change
but I will be more mindful respectful of
people's personal space and that's a
good thing that's a good thing totally
the wrong response it's the wrong
response for about a hundred different
reasons first of all why is Joe Biden in
this mess in the first place he's in
this mess because the guy is basically a
walking simper he's just a set of teeth
with legs he just his entire political
career is not based on conviction it's
based on ingratiating himself to people
that's why he does all the hugs and the
kisses and the nuzzles he just wants to
ingratiate himself and how do you
ingratiate yourself in the old school of
politics in the pre reality TV
pre-social media pre Donald Trump era
you were this saccharine pseudo earnest
I just really care I just really want to
build people up and encourage people and
smile with my giant fake teeth and
encourage people and hey there you can
do it and it's this overly saccharine
totally performative thing but that was
the old school of politics that's Joe
Biden's entire career and so he's first
of all he that got him into this mess in
the first place because all the fake
little nuzzles and hugs and knows eskimo
kisses or whatever he's doing to these
people does look weird in this more
gritty authentic reality TV school of
politics but what his response does is
grants the premise so he doesn't quite
apologize but what he says is listen
I've we've had changing societal norms
maybe I've made some people
uncomfortable I'm gonna change that no
don't in this moment in politics look
maybe this will change hopefully this
will change in five years or something
at this moment the minute that you admit
fault you're dead every me too person
survived except for Kevin Spacey why cuz
he's the only
to admit he did anything wrong Donald
how many how many things that people
lobbed at Donald Trump some fake attacks
some real attacks his school of thought
is that old mob school deny till you die
that's what Joe Biden should have done
here and the reason he should have done
it is because he actually didn't really
do anything wrong he's done a lot of
things wrong in his political career
there are a lot of reasons not to vote
for him which we'll get to in one second
but in this hugging politics but that's
his whole politics that's retail
politics what his response should have
been because he should have released a
response he should have gotten that
little cell phone camera and posted this
on Twitter whatever and he should have
said this is a BS political attack this
is being launched by my opponents this
is being launched by the Bernie Sanders
campaign and it is outrageous they are
accusing me of sexual predation the
sexual assault with no evidence
whatsoever and they are making a mockery
of the me2 movement they are making a
mockery of the real victims of sexual
assault this is offensive to real
victims these people should apologize
for what they are trying to do for their
cynical political attack I will never
apologize for encouraging people in
politics and having a personal
relationship with my constituents find
me one woman who credit can credibly
accused me of sexual impropriety or
adultery or sexual assault find me one
woman find me one hotel room booking
find me one bit of evidence and until
you do
shut your cynical mouths that's what he
should have said it would have played a
lot better first of all and it would
have been correct it would have been
just
he actually the one thing you can't get
Joe Biden on as far as we know is sexual
misconduct you he'd probably be in a
better space of you could Teddy Kennedy
let his mistress drown in a car Bob
Menendez almost certainly had sex with
underage prostitutes in the Dominican
Republic federal prosecutors certainly
think he did Bill Clinton we'd caught
Bill Clinton and he survived impeachment
Joe Biden is sort of the exception here
and that he actually isn't sexually
improper Joe by the thing to go after
Joe Biden for
is that he's a total hack he is at the
most disingenuous unctuous politician in
the country who will say anything to win
a vote because he's so desperate to
appeal to every single person that he's
gonna nuzzle them with his nose and give
them butterfly kisses frankly the one
way that I could see this fake scandal
rebounding to Joe Biden's benefit is
that it's seems to be covering up in the
media the actual scandal that he's
involved in the actual impropriety that
he's involved in which is basically that
he bullied Ukraine into paying his son
millions of dollars oh you haven't heard
about this I'm not surprised because no
mainstream media outlets are covering it
but this is the real scandal that Joe
Biden
is hiding right now Joe Biden's son
hunter his younger son Hunter received
millions of dollars from a Ukrainian
energy company called buries m'a
holdings while his father was vice
president while his father was the main
US official dealing with Ukrainian
affairs and while Joe Biden was
funneling 1.8 billion dollars to Ukraine
coincidentally while Joe Biden was
funneling all of that money to Ukraine
his son Hunter received millions of
dollars million he received regular
monthly payments of 166 thousand dollars
per month from buries m'a why is that is
it because hunter Biden is some expert
on Ukrainian US relations no is it
because hunter Biden is an expert on
Russian Ukrainian relations no is it
because hunter Biden is an expert on
energy policy no he got the money as a
payoff crony deal because his father was
threatening to withhold money from
Ukraine until he got this sweetheart
deal listen Joe Biden actually it's
basically bragged about this at the
Council on Foreign Relations in December
of 2015
gotten a commitment from poroshenko they
would take action against a state
prosecutor and they didn't I said I'm
telling you're not getting a billion
dollars I said you're not getting a
billion I'm gonna be leaving here I
think
about six hours I looked I said
believing in six hours and the
prosecutors not fired you're not getting
the money Oh son of a got fired and they
put in place someone who was solid at
the time coincidentally by the way the
party is leaving out of this bragging at
CFR is that the prosecutor that he made
sure to get fired was looking into the
chrony deals that hunter Biden had with
Purisima isn't it a little weird that
the Vice President of the United States
main point person on Ukrainian US
relations is saying we're gonna withhold
almost two billion dollars of aid if you
don't fire this one prosecutor what's
wrong with that prosecutor what on earth
could that prosecutor have to do with us
Ukrainian relations oh not very much
he's actually just looking into your son
and the cojones on Joe Biden you got to
give him that at least he brags about it
at the Council on Foreign Relations this
is a real scandal this is real
corruption this is a real reason that
Joe Biden should not be President
also it's collusion this is kind of the
funny thing - its guy guess it's
Ukrainian collusion or is it Russian
collusion I don't know but it is
collusion that's a real reason
demagoguing and race hustling in saying
the MIT Romney wants to put black people
back in Chains that's a reason that he
shouldn't be president the fact that he
is a plagiarist why which is why he had
to drop out of the 1988 presidential
race that's a reason that he shouldn't
be president who in the issue with the
plagiarism being that Joe Biden is an
empty suit he's a walking grin he's a
walking butterfly kiss that's all he is
all good reasons to prevent Joe Biden
from being president but to pretend that
he's a child molester with no evidence
whatsoever other than some YouTube video
where he's taking a photo with a family
and he like touches a girl's hair or
something come on give me a break
Kamala Harris just came out you'll be
shocked and said I believe Joe's
accusers that's fine look I'm perfectly
willing to enjoy the schadenfreude ax
while the Democrats rip each other apart
and Joe Biden one of the Dismas
disingenuous politicians in the country
goes down just before the finish line
again for the third time I'm perfectly
happy to watch it but we shouldn't
delude ourselves we shouldn't pretend
that the issue is that Joe Biden smelled
some lady's hair on the campaign trail
in 2002 or something it just distracts
from the real issues with which is that
this guy really is an old crook he
really is an old crone maybe not as bad
as Hillary Clinton but he is engaging in
crooked deals he's been in the he was in
the Senate for what 40 years he's been
in politics for almost 50 years he led
the high-tech lynching against Clarence
Thomas plenty of reasons to go after
this guy and fortunately it seems like
he's never gonna be President if he can
survive it though if he can survive it
ironically talk about for DHS it will be
because he's using these stupid fake
scandals to distract from the real
scandal speaking of bad politics though
I hate to go after one of our own but I
have to critique him GOP representative
Matt gates is offering an answer to a o
C's green New Deal
he just held a press conference about
right in front of the Capitol on what he
is calling the green real deal and it
was just a textbook example of bad
politics we'll go through it point by
point my name's Matt gates I represent
Florida's first congressional district
while it is above water just yesterday
the Secretary of the Air Force the
Secretary of the army the Chiefs of
Staff of both the Army and the Air Force
testified to the House Armed Services
Committee that in real-time climate
change is impacting the strategic
decisions that our military makes
regarding weapons testing basing
decisions the global movement of humans
and high stakes territorial claims made
by our adversaries in the Arctic our
military does not have the luxury of an
academic debate about climate change
they must respond to the reality that we
face today and so should the United
States Congress history will judge
harshly my Republican colleagues who
deny the science of climate change
similarly those Democrats who would use
climate change as a basis to regulate
out of existence the American experience
will face the harsh reality that their
ideas will fail today along with other
members of Congress I'll be filing a
green real deal a common-sense rebuttal
to the green New Deal aah-aah
everything about this was wrong every
it's not even like that bad of an idea
but everything about the execution was
wrong I say this with great good will
toward Matt Gaetz
not a good roll at how so first of all
all the optics when you're a member of
Congress you're basically a spokesman
you're basically a performer you are a
wet mouthpiece for the policy ideas that
you and others around you want to pursue
that's most of your power you don't have
a whole lot of raw political power what
you mostly have is the power of a
microphone and the power of television
cameras a good example of someone using
this properly is Dan Crenshaw who is
very intelligent and a serious minded
person and actually good at his job so
Dan Crenshaw one is a freshman member of
Congress one of billion people there he
is able to use his platforms Twitter
going on TV news going on the internet
or whatever he is able to use those very
effectively to convey important policy
ideas important philosophical ideas
important ideological ideas okay this is
the opposite of that first of all when
you hold a press conference in front of
the Capitol you need to have people
behind you I know this seems
counterintuitive because you have a
microphone ostensibly you're speaking to
people the people that you're speaking
to at a press conference are on the
internet they're behind television sets
they're not the people in front of you
so you need people behind you to show
that your idea has support here Matt
Gaetz is just all by himself the only
people behind him are tourists walking
by looking at him kind of funny so from
an optics level not a great point also
he's wearing a neon green tie that makes
him look silly if he wants to wear a
green tie I like that idea where a dark
green tie where a sober green tie make
yourself look see
he also has a baby-blue pocket square
that clashes with a neon green tie as do
most things lose it not a good idea
basically 99% of members of Congress in
the Senate by suits that wouldn't have
fit their own grandfather's tailor your
suit just look cleaner more presentable
aoc and all of these guys are actually
pretty good at Optics most of the time
the GOP needs to be good at optics too
okay
then the sign in front of the the press
conferences it says the green New Deal
and then it's crossed out and it says
real a deal yeah we're the real deal
awful awful stuff when you are just
responding to your opponent's you are
losing because you're playing on their
terms in this case you're literally
accepting their term you're say okay
okay the green New Deal is the basis and
I'm just sort of responding and in this
case it's like crossed out with a marker
yeah we're we're the cool we're the real
deal awful not good it reminds me of the
mom and main girls I'm not a I'm not a
regular mom I'm a cool mom that's what
some of these Republicans are doing when
they were accepting the left's terms and
into the broader point they're accepting
the left's premises and this is where we
get to that pseudo earnestness that Joe
Biden is exhibiting this idea the pseudo
hey look I really care about climate
change
I represent Florida well it's still
above water I'm really no come on man
that the problem with these climate
change people is that they're hysterical
alarmists you are not going to defeat
their arguments by accepting their
alarmist premises it's about to be
underwater and I'm serious about it no
it's not it's just not Florida is not
gonna be under I know Al Gore told us
Florida was gonna be underwater by like
2012 but it didn't happen it was never
going to happen it's not gonna be
underwater by 2024 it's not gonna be
underwater by 2050 it ain't gonna happen
so stop accepting the alarmist premises
because if you accept the alarmist
premises then you basically give them
the argument if you accept the premise
that Florida is eminently going to be
underwater then why shouldn't we upend
the entire economy and all of American
governance in society if
whole states are gonna be submerged
under water in this catastrophe of
course we should mobilize problem is
that isn't going to happen don't accept
those premises you don't need to fight
on their terms it's a bad political look
so I I don't think this is going to go
anywhere but I would urge all of our
other friends in Congress not to accept
this stuff it's a total loser
if you've got two people selling the
green New Deal and one of them is a GOP
representative in an ill-fitting suit
and the other one is a OC who is
basically a product of social media
they're gonna win the left is gonna win
that we are never going to win that
fight okay
speaking of AR C she has made a blunder
because AOC has become a punch line
she was always we were talking about
this yesterday she was always walking
this line is she a punch liner is she
winning she won she upended a longtime
incumbent Joe Crowley in Congress she's
become one of the most prominent members
of Congress she's directly challenged
Nancy Pelosi and she goes straight to
the people she says I'm not here to
convince my colleagues I'm here to
convince the American people now the
trouble with AOC right now she's finally
lost something
she lost the green New Deal that that
crazy piece of legislation that she
wrote that she got everyone to talk
about she even got Matt gates to talk
about it
she got members of the Senate to
co-sponsor this bill and then cocaine
Mitch nuclear cocaine Mitch comes up he
says we're all gonna vote on it they he
plays chicken and they all cave she lost
she took the loss and so what she's got
to do now is pivot she's got to go on
the attack somewhere else she can't keep
fighting this battle cuz she's losing
this battle and you see this here so she
does one of her weirdo live streams but
this one is different than the others
she's not laughing at people she's not
above the fray she's not winning the
media war
she's reactive she's explaining she's
defending she's losing
until the world ends again we have 12
years left to cut emissions by at least
50%
if not more and everyone who wants me to
joke about that you may laugh but your
grandkids will not so understand that
the internet documents everything and
for all those people you know you want
to look about Montag while looking in
the back of history looking backwards
you look back and you open history books
on the civil rights movement and you see
those folks who are protesting against
the ability for African Americans and
black Americans to have the right to
vote you should also know that the
internet documents everything and your
grandchildren will not be able to hide
the fact that you fought against
acknowledging and taking bold actions on
climate change ah not her best work and
she doesn't even hear she's there
crouching in what looks like a wood shop
it's a really awful framing you can't
really tell where she is she's crouching
in this really weird way and then she
says you know the Internet is forever
[ __ ] you aren't you guys gonna look
silly in 20 years somebody's gonna look
silly in 20 years I don't think it's
gonna be us but okay now by the way this
is still a more effective way to
communicate the green new deal than what
Matt Gaetz was doing much more at least
this is innovative at least this is
capturing people's attention at least
this doesn't look totally contrived but
it's still weak she's got to back off of
this if she wants to maintain her
primacy in the among the Democrat House
members she's just looking crazy here
she's not really convincing anybody with
these arguments the internet is forever
I mean it's actually the same reason
because she's just responding she's just
reacting what you saw Matt gates doing
was he's responding and reacting to her
what you see her doing is she's worse
and reacting to the people who were
mocking her total devastating loss on
the Senate vote on the green New Deal
don't do it when you're what was Ronald
Reagan would say when you're explaining
you're losing it's the same kind of
language here it's all the same kind of
language how do you do this what is the
what you need to do what Joe Biden
should have done what Matt Gaetz should
have done what aoc should have done you
have to be very direct you have to be
uncompromising you have to not accept
the premises of the other people you see
for the first time there a OSI is
starting to accept the premises she says
okay I'm not saying the world is going
to end in 12 years I'm saying it's gonna
start to end in 12 years
yeah that's not quite what you said
that's not quite what you said before
but okay I mean this is more - but
you're just that doesn't work as well
you've got to be direct you've got to be
blunt you've got to call out the
absurdity we will call out the absurdity
in just a second on how men are not
women and how men are also not puppies
we'll also get to the mailbag but first
you got to go to daily wire comm head
over there ten bucks a month hundred
dollars for an annual membership you get
me at the end of flame and sure you get
the Ben Shapiro sure you get them out
well show you test questions in the
mailbag coming up you get to ask
questions backstage you're gonna do
their Kingdom and you get this all right
you listen the Internet is forever
but you might not be forever if you
don't get the leftist ears tumblr
because the tears are coming Florida's
going to be underwater you could drown
get your tumblr we'll be right back
you've got to call out the absurdity
directly you've got to take it on
directly uncompromising ly if you try to
accept people's premises if you try to
be really nice and conciliatory and I'm
a really nice guy you're gonna lose this
is coming from Teen Vogue to explain to
all of us why men are really women hi
I'm Hannah Gabby and I'm here to tell
you the binary is both sexes typically
refers to your biological traits as your
gonads your genitalia your internal sex
characteristics your hormone production
hormone response and secondary sex
characteristics gender is about your
identity your expression and it's often
based on ideas about sex it's important
that we really break down what are we
talking about when we talk about sex and
gender and is there something called
biological sex and what does that mean
this idea that the body is either male
or female is totally wrong and I am
living proof of that
we know intersex people exist and break
down this binary we all have
characteristics that are typically male
and typically female and it is really
about political choices
social factors ideological choices that
we assign meaning to different parts of
our body so the meaning may be that the
thing that most of us are taught that if
you have a vagina you're a girl or if
you have a penis you're a boy but like
many simple binaries break down when you
start to really get into the
nitty-gritty yeah things are getting
gritty and nitty that's true things are
breaking down but it doesn't dispute the
fact that men are not women and women
are not men what one of those guys says
is that what we have is body parts
biological facts that we assign meaning
to but we can assign whatever meaning we
want
it's like Humpty Dumpty in Alice in
Wonderland he says in my language words
can mean whatever I want them to mean
well which is to be master to use the
words correctly or to use the words
however you want them to mean whatever
they want to mean actually what you have
is body parts you have biological facts
that have meaning they themselves have
meaning that is not reliant on what you
think the meaning is or what you want
the meaning to be that person in there
says there are intersex people what he
means is what we traditionally have been
called hermaphrodites people who have
either confusing looking genitals or
even confusing chromosomes people who
blur the lines this is an infinitely
infinitesimally small number of people
but of course those people exist
nevertheless men and women exist there
are like oars
there are lion there's a hybrid of a
lion and a tiger the fact that ligers
exist does not mean that lions and
tigers also do not exist and that lions
and tigers are different and the lions
are not tigers and tigers are not lions
but ligers exist right that's true there
are a very very small number of ligers
nevertheless the categories of lion and
tiger exist they're a very very small
number of intersex people nevertheless
the category of man and woman male and
female still exist you have to call that
out you cannot say out of a false sense
of compassion that oh well maybe hey
maybe you're right maybe there's no such
thing as men and women well I mean
what's what's the harm if we just
indulge people who think that they're
really the opposite sex or they very
much want to be the opposite sex
here is the harm of indulging delusion
care of the human puppies in the United
Kingdom freeze oh yeah help yourself oh
okay good you can't okay so whilst he's
having his treat because he's been very
good puppy so far but you were you were
engaged yeah and when well we split up
2008 yeah so how much of this did you
know when you're going on bits of he
didn't have the suit then so this is a
grown man wearing a giant leather suit
that makes him look like a Dalmatian
puppy and he identifies as a puppy even
though he's a man and he's quite
convinced that really on some deeper
level he is a puppy he said
quote I realized that my behaviors were
quite doglike in childhood probably from
the age of six no one ever talked about
it it was never mentioned my parents
took early retirement we moved to a farm
in Norfolk it wasn't until the internet
arrived in our house that I started
chatting to people online mostly through
groups and message boards I was
incredibly nervous when I first started
talking to people online I was living
with my parents and I would sneak
downstairs at 3 in the morning to get on
the internet and look for this stuff I
would hold a pillow over the 56k modem
so that you couldn't hear the modem
noise I was worried that if I ever spoke
to anyone about it they would be like
you're a nut job it's an experience that
a lot of pups I know have had feeling
really weird and strange about how they
are and then finding other people and
feeling a lot better about it there is
no difference between a man who thinks
he's a puppy and a man who thinks that
he's a woman I don't mean that in any
sort of mean way or spiteful way or
hateful way these are people who have
psychological disorders and they deserve
compassion and treatment they do not
deserve to be deluded or to have their
delusions indulged in this guy obviously
also has a sexual fetish that involves
pretending that he's an animal
kind of like bado who is a furry we'll
get into that at some other at some
other episode but but this guy was
engaged to a woman and now he pretends
that he's her puppy that's how this
works no one gains when you indulge
delusion no one gains when you indulge
in fantasy that's a false compassion
don't be the unctuous glad-handing
walking simper who tells everyone
whatever they think that they want to
hear you got a call call things like
they are you got to call it like you see
it we get a lot of bad politics when you
don't do that but beyond just the realm
of pure government and politics you just
have bad interactions with human beings
when you're not direct with them when
you don't call it like you see it when
you're trying to be everything to
everybody this is especially true in
these hot button social issues like
transgenderism where you could face
social consequences if you speak obvious
truths you could speak professional code
you can face professional consequences
if you speak obvious truths we're not
going to get along very well in a
culture of lies what Drupal even calls
the Empire of Lies you got to be honest
I know this seems counterintuitive in
politics but you got to try let's get to
the mailbag let's try to answer directly
and honestly in the mailbag from David
Michael thank you for mentioning Leon
Kass and the wisdom of repugnance on
your show
I've long respected casts do you think
there is any hope our culture will start
to have serious discussions about
bioethical issues IVF abortion or
cloning or technical advancement
technological advancement bound to
trample on the sanctity of human life
thanks love the show David I'm hopeful
in the sense that I don't know you're
asking about it so I guess that I'm
hopeful about that I'm hopeful because
there is the alternative media there are
the new media now so people can get into
these discussions if they really seek
them out I'm not that hopeful because
podcasts are a shoddy substitute for
church podcasts are a shoddy substitute
for a firm moral foundation for a sound
religious foundation so while the new
media the alternative media podcasts are
becoming much much more popular church
attendance is declining religious
instruction is declining moral
instruction is declining our moral
vocabulary is going extinct we're losing
the ability to discuss these things so
now even I hear self-described
conservatives say this they say Michael
I know you're talking about the culture
and philosophy and religion but I just
want you got to talk about facts and
science and facts you don't even know
what those words mean if you're drawing
a dichotomy between philosophy and
culture and and religion and facts or
science then you don't know what those
words mean you lack the vocabulary to
engage in those sort of discussions
which are relatively sophisticated for
our debased dialogue but they're
essential if you're going to talk about
fundamental questions such as abortion
cloning in vitro fertilization the
dignity of human life if if our culture
continues down that scientistic and
shallow path I'm I can't say
that I look forward to a future where
we're going to be able to discuss those
things in greater clarity I think what
you'll see is you'll see people society
bifurcate you're going to have some
people who have a fairly sophisticated
vocabulary with which to discuss those
and then a lot of people who are simply
never given that instruction from birth
all the way up through adulthood a
strong solid moral and linguistic
foundation even as necessary for that
from David hello Michael for Poetry
Month I have written a haiku
are you satisfied cheers Dave I'm very
satisfied David from Arnaldo dear Pedro
some people believe that the current
condition of tribalism in the parties
started with the Republican Party in the
Newt Gingrich transfer of power but my
Hillsdale professor says that this
started after Watergate when Democrats
left Republicans in the dark and
congressional affairs when did tribalism
begin or nalddo tribalism has recurred
many times throughout history if what
you're talking about is our current
American political tribalism where it
seems like no one can compromise
whatsoever I tend to agree a little bit
more with your Hillsdale professor but I
would go back further I think it begins
with Watergate itself I think Watergate
is the moment that tribalism begins
because you had Democrats who were so
furious that they lost a presidential
election in a landslide to a guy that
they had previously stolen a
presidential election from in 1960 to a
guy that they never forgave because he
was correct about Alger Hiss about a
communist spy working in the federal
government at a high level
he called them out on it Richard Nixon
the left defended this guy Richard Nixon
was right they never forgave him for it
and so what they did was they used a
bunch of political dirty tricks and
leaks to overturn a presidential
election that Nixon won in a landslide
it was watering it and the Republicans
let them do it because the Republicans
were playing by a more dignified set of
political stand
the Republicans hadn't got the message
that politics was going to become
utterly tribal at that point it began
then it was totally unjust when they did
it they haven't let up since from
Sheamus hi Michael what's the difference
between a political philosophy and a
political ideology under which category
if any does conservatism fall an
excellent question
ideology is quite specific
Michael Oakshott the great conservative
philosopher defines ideology as the
formalized abridgement of the supposed
substratum of rational truth contained
in the tradition he gives that
definition in rationalism and politics
it's a bulky definition so think about
it the formalized abridgement of the
supposed substratum of rational truth
contained in the tradition there's
another definition of ideology which is
given by slavo asiak the philosopher and
communist has popularized this although
he kind of Cribs it from both David
Foster Wallace and Erica Jong the
novelist which is that the way we see
ideology is everywhere even in the most
mundane and trivial objects even in
toilet bowls so in Germany the hole in
the toilet bowl is at the front of the
bowl so you see the excrement you see it
there in the German metaphysical
philosophical analytical approach to
things you see the excrement in the
French toilet bowl the hole is in the
back it just goes right away it's just
it's more elegant it's more radical it's
more revolutionary and in the United
Kingdom and in America the hole is in
the bottom but there's a there's a lot
of water all around it so the excrement
goes into the water and you don't have
to it's there but you know you don't
have to really you're not supposed to
inspect it like those weirdo Germans do
it's a sort of via made yet somewhere in
the middle it's more moderate and this
he says is ideology ideology we see it
in everything it's like the John
Carpenter film they live it's the
glasses
we have ideology on our billboard
sinara this in everything and then you
can put the glasses on or take the
glasses off really is what it should be
and then you see the bare facts as they
are it's very painful to get rid of
ideology in any case what all of those
people are saying is that ideology is
very narrow it's it's you're not seeing
reality unvarnished you're not seeing
truth unvarnished we all bring
ideological presuppositions to the way
we view the world conservatism I
actually don't even use the term
conservatism too much or I try not to
because what the Conservatives should do
is fight ideology tooth and nail as best
he can a lot of different ideologies in
the conservative movement
neoconservatism libertarianism the
religious right all of these different
ideologies what we should do however is
go back to that Oakshott definition and
say that what the conservative does is
conserve the conservative prefers the
tried to the untried the conservative
Revere's the tradition venerates the
tradition believes in prescription if
something has worked for a very long
time maybe I shouldn't totally upend it
in a night that is not quite an ideology
but that is as a veneration for
tradition because of the perils of
ideology it's a long and disgusting
explanation of the difference between
ideology and philosophy but we should
prefer philosophy we should prefer the
view of ideology like Dziedzic is a
philosopher so he's viewing ideology and
trying to take all of it in that's what
a conservative should try to take all of
it in and proceed cautiously with good
judgment with prudence with veneration
with prescription from Nicole will trump
become a punchline if he loses in 2020
yes not as badly as if he had lost in
2016 but he will he will because in the
United States were very harsh on our
one-term presidents Jimmy Carter's a
punchline even George HW Bush is a
punchline even Richard Nixon is
punchline he wasn't just a one-term
president but he got kicked out so he's
become a punchline
we're not very nice to our one-term
president and if President Trump is a
one-term president he'll be a punchline
as well so we got a we got to get the
guy reelected because he's done a lot of
good stuff there's still a lot more good
stuff we could do and it's important
historically to look back on this era
and say that was a good era we should
have more of that that's how you build a
path to success in the future from
Jeremy hello Michael my mother is in
hospice and we'll be entering the active
state of dying soon very sorry to hear
that I'm going to give her eulogy could
you recommend a poem a piece of
scripture or other form of a written
word for inspiration to help guide my
writing Thank You Jeremy it's a very
difficult thing to eulogize your mother
a little bit of advice I could give is
it is very important what you say is
very important it's going to stick with
you it's going to matter this is the
moment you've got to get it right I
don't mean to put extra pressure on you
but you've got to get it right you're
smart to say is there a poem is there a
piece of scripture is there something
that I should use you know your mother
you should choose the poem you should
choose the bit of Scripture you
shouldn't get a canned piece of
scripture from somebody else who doesn't
know your mother you should choose it
but it should be about that it should be
about your mother it should be about her
should not be about you it should not be
about it should not be indulgent it
should not be sakura and it should not
be sentimental and it should look at the
life of your mother and it should look
beyond that you know when father Paul
Scalia was eulogizing his father Antonin
Scalia he actually kind of had a funny
opening he said he said we're all here
because of one man a man who was it was
loved by some and hated by others a
deeply polarizing man a man who who
changed the world
I speak of course of Jesus Christ and
all the people there because that is the
point he was looking beyond there was a
another friend of mine told me about how
he was asked to give a eulogy by a man
who knew that he was dying and he said
preach the gospel this is I think the
right idea because you're not just
giving soft soap to people first of all
I don't know how old you are it under
the circumstances an important thing
when you're eulogizing your mother
especially if you're young is to let
people know not only will you be okay
not only will they will be okay it will
be okay life will go on it will be okay
and so you should do that and then speak
about her it that in a way that involves
love and reverence and reality and
respect and truth in a way that you will
be proud to do it to look back on that
later on this this may be one of the
hardest things you ever do it's going to
be grueling it awful to write it and to
give it and but you'll be glad that you
didn't screw it up and that you didn't
take it lightly all right we got a lot
more to get to but that's our show come
back on Monday in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa Elvira production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey guys
over on the Matt Walsh show today we're
gonna talk a little bit about this Joe
Biden thing he struggles to respect
personal space is that a huge scandal
that we should all care about I don't
think so but we'll talk about it also a
woman just recently gave birth to her
son's child we will look at the lengths
that people go to in order to get around
biology and also we'll deal with this
question should christians cite the
Bible when they're arguing about
cultural issues with people who don't
believe in the Bible I say no and I'll
explain why today over on the Matt Walsh
show